Let's go next to our caller from the six one
four area code.
Who's calling today from six one four?
Hello.
Yes, that's you.
Oh, I'm just saying is my name.
Oh, you're calling.
You're calling from it's country code 61.
It's called Cut.
Where are you calling?
Yeah.
Going from Australia.
Wow.
Victoria.
Yeah.
Thank you for taking my call.
I've tried a few times and I saw it from the
comment.
You know, this is great now.
Yeah.
I have.
So I live in Victoria, Melbourne and Melbourne,
just out of.
I do know the geography.
I'm sure you.
Of course.
Yeah.
I suppose you could ask a lot of questions.
I could write or talk.
A lot of things.
But I do have a question for you and I don't
want to waste your time.
You call it beautiful thought.
Yeah, I.
Yes.
Do you have any questions for me?
No.
Well, none whatsoever.
Now, you know.
I know that.
I mean.
Well, whole.
No.
Here's my question.
This is good.
Yeah.
I'll ask you the questions.
Let me ask you the questions.
Is the United States a laughing stock right
now in Australia?
Gore.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, I mean, look, I mean,
I I'm informed I lived in New York City for
ten years.
In London for three years.
I've I've I have close friends, family and
friends there.
So I'm keeping up to date.
Via shows like yours and, you know, stuff
I can watch without you.
You know, I like to keep myself informed.
However, yeah, unfortunately it is.
I mean, when I was saying there were issues,
the health care system, I mean, the.
Yeah.
And I left just after Barack Obama was.
Elected, you know, a really exciting time.
And and, yeah, it is.
And to be quite honest, I'm just waiting for
this whole long, exhausting and torture of
reality show to be over.
Right.
Hopes the last episode is in November because
there's not another season.
Because it.
It's.
Some people might say, okay, well, you're
not an American, OK, nationalistic attitude.
We're a global society.
I mean, 40 years now.
And I have been ramping up.
I can say everything that's going on over
the world.
Mentally, it's it's exhausting.
I mean, I think once I saw that to Pennsylvania,
La Trobe.
Yes, Don.
Yeah.
I watched it through your show because, I
mean, you know, it was sort of a buffer that
I had to.
I couldn't find the remote not to unplug the
television streaming for me.
Right.
I'm shocked you didn't throw the TV out the
window altogether, actually.
Sorry.
Yeah, I know some people reported throwing
that, unplugging the TV wasn't enough, they
had to throw the TV out the window altogether.
Yeah.
Like a man because of his string from your
devices.
Like I said.
Or something doesn't turn out so much.
No one had to go outside.
Right.
And then, you know, I've decided that you've
got the posters post Parcel Service, which
and then I'm on the other side of the military,
honestly.
Really.
And I think to myself, I'm happy you.
Do you want to get out?
Is that what you want?
So not.
Right.
But.
Like criticizing the military.
These two sacred institutions.
And John McCain.
Yes.
Well, listen, you've hit all only how important
topics and a number of different things there.
We we we hope to do well by the Australian
people in November and to remove Donald Trump.
I hope it happens and I hope to hear from
you again.
Yeah.
I've got one question for you.
Oh, you do?
OK.
Why hasn't there been a Trump gate?
So sorry, what?
Why what?
Why hasn't there been a Trump gate?
Why hasn't why hasn't something been called
Trump?
I have no idea.
I'm not sure I will make a phone call and
try to find out.
Trump.
Not Trump.
Well, what about Trump?
No, I understand.
I understand.
Yeah.
No, I mean, I don't know why there's been
nothing.
Too many.
Too many of them.
Right.
OK.
Thank you so much for the call.
I do appreciate it.
My pleasure.
No, the pleasure is all on this side of the
phone line.
Hope to hear from you again.